it is now Beyond any doubt that radical
lunatic extremist repugnant conspiracy
theorist congresswoman Marjorie Taylor
green wants to be Donald Trump's Vice
President we suspected this from the way
she was acting we also suspected Kerry
Lake wanted to be Donald Trump's vice
president but Steve Bannon and others
are now saying Marjorie wants it and you
know what I say lettering we know how
well it worked out for the late Senator
John McCain back in 2008 to select what
was that woman's name Sarah Palin to be
his running mate it didn't work out well
Marjorie Taylor green is even more
Bonkers than Sarah Palin I'm not
defending Palin I'm just saying green is
even crazier and I think it's exactly
the sort of insanity that Trump needs to
even further turn his campaign into a
bigger Sideshow than it already is what
do you think let me know in the comments
Marjorie Taylor green is Trump's VP
helpful to Trump or destructive to Trump